I mean you mentioned a few times kind of
having to choose between what you wanted
to do in life in a relationship right
and I think there's a lot of pressure on
people especially under 30 to make that
choice and to get settled down if
there's someone listening right now and
let's suppose they have something that's
a good offer or they have something
that's promising in one city and then
they have someone in another city that
they probably still care about and a
life that's quote unquote planned out
but they're on the on the fence what
what kind of like let's say big brother
advice would you give someone follow
your heart you have to always follow
your heart because if somebody has your
life planned out for you that's a
problem right there because unless you
have your life planned out the same way
they have it planned out it's not gonna
work because eventually you're gonna you
know you heard that you always hear
about people outgrowing each other
well they've we we all grew each other
what that means is you didn't outgrow
them you just grew up you know and you
know I'm saying I mean it's not like you
don't care I love them it's just that
you you've evolved when I say grow up
you've you evolved into who you are who
you want to be and if if if it's not in
that cookie cutter kind of thing that
they have planned for you and you know
you they have you boxed in here you know
have you boxed in and you grow and you
outside of that box that's constantly so
you have to you have to be who you who
you are in in in and hopefully that
person or someone else will be in line
with what you're doing because you got
to be happy I mean nothing worse than
being in a relationship I've been there
where you know you're trying to be
something that you're not you're trying
to conform to somebody else's
expectations trying to be what they want
you to be it's not gonna work because
eventually you're gonna you're gonna
boat from that you're gonna run from
that because the real you is always
gonna come
forward you can't be funny in a
relationship you can't it's impossible
because eventually you go you can't be
you can't act in a relationship you can
act on stage you can act you know
wherever else but you can't act in a
relationship you can't be this person
yes dear whatever you do you can't do
that but so long eventually you're gonna
just say oh [ __ ] this I can't do this
and then you know it's gonna it's gonna
explode
so you have to you know you have to be
you and and if it means that you have to
you know let that relationship go then
you have to let it go I mean life is
hard as we all know I mean you can't you
can't be what somebody else wants you to
be you have to be who you want to be and
like I said if it doesn't fit what they
want you to be to then it's not gonna
work do you think creative people have a
tougher time in a relationship then and
I'm not saying people that have a
nine-to-five aren't creative oh yeah but
but people that choose creativity as
their as their vocation as well as their
passion sort of thing yeah why why do
you think that is because to be an
artist of whatever type whether you're
painter a musician or whatever you know
rapper or whatever to be that you have
to really really dedicate yourself to
that to be good in it because there's
competition and you know when you first
start out all right yeah I mean there's
no competition I mean yeah Yanni is
because in this world and then being a
professional out here you have to be
really really into what you do now I'm
going to tell you something personally I
used to smoke a lot of weed and get high
back way back years ago and I had a
buddy of mine who was actually the guys
selling me the weed back home pull me
aside I mean I'm at his place beautiful
beautiful houses you know he pulls me
got all the buddies sitting around you
know smoking weed cause I used to love
smoking weed now don't get
oh I loved it but he pulled me aside and
he said Kimi I want to talk to you so
all the guys sitting and say oh he's
gonna take him to the good stuff the
good stash should know another room
he got me another room he says you know
what he said me and you've been friends
since the fifth grade
he said you just you live in Chicago you
going to Hollywood you said you can't be
getting high like this out there
he said the competition is heavy you're
gonna be going up against the major
people for stuff he said you got to
focus more you got to get out of this
and that stuck to me that stuck to me
I'm lame
Wow and he says I don't have to sell you
none of this stuff I got customers all
over buying my weed and whatever I don't
have to do that with you me and you were
like best friends like brothers you say
you got a thing in terms of you know
sacrificing something to get what you
want to go Wow so shortly after that I
quit smoking weed it's been over 27
years now Wow you know and I smoked so
much that people were like you quit that
late yeah because I had to say you know
what he was right and once I stopped
doing that things started really falling
into place my focus and my concentration
got stronger and it's not because okay
my mind wasn't cloudy from weak because
I've been smoking weed was fun to me you
know and and but it became a point where
okay it's it's a thing a discipline so
getting back to what you were saying
it's all about it's all about being who
you are and being honest with yourself
about who you are and not let anybody
sidetrack you you can't be you can't be
what a way for a girlfriend or if you're
a woman or whatever or a guy with a
boyfriend or whatever you can't let
somebody take you away from who you are
and what you want to be because being an
artist is not a job it's a calling it's
a life we all artistic your artistic we
all are artists this is a life for us
and you have to explain to people and
see 9:00 to 5:00 people they have a
tendency to
things in the sense of a job okay yeah
well we get jobs I mean I just did a job
and I got a couple coming up in the
business but it's my life it's not like
okay I'm gonna cut it off you know yeah
I I cut it off a lot of times when I get
home cuz I'm watching the Lakers or
somebody or you know watching something
on TV or something more sitting around
you know doing something or reading a
book or something yeah you have to
unwind and relax and get away from stuff
at times but you have to know who you
are
you have to know who you are and you
have to say okay this is Who I am
you gotta accept me for who I am well I
got to go and that happened to me a
couple of times you know way saying okay
this is not it for me I'm like hey now
the first one probably still hates me
when I was real young the last one we
became friends and we talk all the time
you know
and she's in Chicago she makes a couple
of hundred three or four hundred
thousand a year got a beautiful house in
Chicago got a Mercedes and all that and
driving around she's very attractive and
she's the businesswoman I'm like hey I'm
happy for you I'm proud of you you know
and I and most of my family and friends
and I grew up with the 95 people so I
don't have any problem with that I just
Know Who I am and I know what's best for
me because like I say I got fired from
every real a real mattified job I've
ever had
I got fired from my first job was a
paperboy they fired me what they fire
you all because I wanted to play
baseball all my friends were playing
baseball and I'm out with a damn wagon
dropping throwing papers up on the porch
you know my friends hitting baseballs
I'm like I'm 12 years old I'm like you
know so I didn't ever said okay I gotta
figure out a way to not get fried
necessarily but I gotta figure out a way
to do as literally this job as possible
so there was a Dairy Queen on the end of
my route and I had in dairy it was like
10 Center with him and I had little
buddies in the neighborhood kids who'd
go with me on my route and I would lay
on my wagon and point to the houses
gonna run to take the papers and sell
them so one of my customers called a man
in to pay
station my manager and he came out and
he says hey what are you doing no setup
like this and he says see me at the end
of the day and I knew you know when I
went back you know to the place I say aw
man I'm in some serious trouble I got
fried so I didn't go home and tell my
mom and daddy that was fried
naturally you know being 12 you kind of
stupid so what you do is like okay I
can't tell mom and daddy I got fired so
I would leave the house every day and go
up to the school you know the little
playground in school and I was sitting
over on the side at the playground for
2-3 hours every day sit there like I was
on my route and finally one day a train
it was raining cats and dogs I mean it
wasn't raining and so I was like oh so I
was leaving out and my dad said oh you
can't go out in the rain I'm gonna go
with you I'm gonna help you do your
route today oh and you know I was always
in trouble for something so my father
says wait a minute wait a minute wait
wait wait you all are going to do your
route I'm like he says what happened so
I had to let him know I got fired
he said you got fired he said when I
said three weeks ago my mama said where
will you go when you leave the house
every day I said I was going up to the
school up there with my little school I
was going up there sitting on the
playground they looked at me like you
have to be out of your mind
so that's what that's what I would do it
I mean you know so I mean I'm telling
you and that started a long long life so
getting fired from every job I mean
every regular job they fry for me from
energy the job I was doing the movie
fans they fired me